Oh my God what a handsome family!
(woman laughs)
It's true.
And you guys are teaming up for something very important
and meaningful we're very excited and honored
that you're gonna talk about it with us here, thank you.
You're doing an exciting new music therapy initiative called
MS in harmony.
Now, Courtney, you have been living with MS
since you were 23, but you've been dancing so much.
May I ask at what juncture did this impact your ability
and at what juncture did you feel like
this is now something I need to make a mission.
So I was like you said, I was diagnosed when I was 23.
And the first thing I asked my doctor was
how is this going to affect my dancing?
Am I going to be able to move?
And the first thing she said to me
was the best thing you could do is to keep moving.
You must keep moving.
So that was music to my ears.
(Ben giggles)
Yeah.
(both laugh)
And I, my grandmother had primary progressive
multiple sclerosis.
And I remember calling the MS society.
I worked with them before I was diagnosed with MS
because of my grandma.
And I was like, surprised I have it, how can I get involved?
What can I do? And I don't really think I gave myself
the opportunity to actually digest the fact that I was
just diagnosed with a chronic neurological illness.
And so I found myself such a great team.
I had great people around me
and then I had my second relapse
and I was dancing for Pit bull at the time.
And we were doing, I think it was the divas live awards.
And I woke up that morning
and I totally lost sight in my left eye.
And it's insane because Mr. Three Oh five,
I had my heels on, I had my like these sexy glasses on
(Ben laughs)
and I was like well, I guess I have a right eye.
So the show must go on.
But I feel like getting involved really helps you.
It makes you feel like you're helping
and what could feel like a very helpless situation.
So, you know getting involved with MS in harmony
has really been such a gift to be able to use music
in such a beautiful and positive way to connect the mind
and the body.
And I'm grateful.
Ben, you're such a musical person,
how does this music therapy work? How does it help people?
So MSinharmony.com is where you can head
to learn all about this.
It's these modules, these little lessons
that Courtney and I both participate in along
with music therapist, a licensed music therapist
and it's little games and exercises that helped you
to get in touch with your body
and to connect your body and mind whether that's you know,
movement breathing, exercises, memory exercises visa-V
creating a tune for a list of things you need
to remember a grocery list or list of names.
And what I really love about it is that as someone
who is a loved one or someone with MS,
and you know, I sometimes feel that it's obviously
a very independent experience in that you know,
Courtney has so much that she needs to face on her own.
And there's so much of the treatment that it's hard
to understand for somebody that isn't going through MS
And so, this particular therapy for MS in harmony
is something that I think is so inclusive of everyone
in the lives of the people that are up against MS.
So it's not only, you know incredibly helpful to the people
who are being treated but also to the caretakers
and the loved ones who can get on board and participate,
participate with their loved ones
and sing along and dance along.
And addition to that, it's not necessarily
for the capital D dancers and capital S singers.
( Courtney chuckles)
It's something that's a very inclusive, very easy program.
That's much more about the mental state
and how powerful music is to change that.
And to put you in touch with your body rather than
singing on key and doing the right steps
This whole thing just sounds like such an incredibly merit
filled thing that you provided for people
and really quickly, Courtney how are you feeling today?
I feel great. I mean, there are days that
I forget I have MS and then there are days where, you know,
I have to give myself a moment
and just kind of let myself feel what I'm feeling.
You know, it's really easy to feel like
you know, I am this super strong person
and I, you know I try to be,
but I also had to realize that it was really important to,
you know let myself grieve a little bit, you know,
it was accepting this new normal.
And I think it's important to surround yourself
with people that love you.
And realize that they want to help you.
Everything is second to health.
Everything comes into perspective when it
has to do with health.
And that is why I think not only all the circumstances
but the anxiety of our mortality and health right now.
So just thank you for sharing this and for more information
on MS in harmony, visit the MSinharmony.com.
We'll also point you to it on our website directly as well.
Thank you guys so much for being here.
Thank you.
Thank you so much!
(people clapping)
Thank you.
(upbeat music)